the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so to start we're gonna recap what
happened last class and last class we
were talking about how traditional
payment systems work and some of the
downsides when you had a bank in the
middle even if you were using techniques
like Chow me and E cash to try to manage
what the bank was doing so just as a
quick reminder we had this kind of setup
where there was Alice and there was Bob
Alice with in order to actually make
transfers Alice had to interact with the
bank and in the case of sort of the
traditional payment system we saw that
the bank could basically just say no
right that it was always possible that a
bank could decide that it didn't like
Alice and it didn't want to process
Alice's transactions we got a little
better than this with Chow me and E cash
but even with Tommy and ecash the bank
was required to do something they were
the ones minting the tokens and they
were the ones redeeming the token so the
banks still played an integral part in
this system and you know that actually
really does make a difference it's not
just a theoretical problem
there are many accounts of people with
for example PayPal accounts who have
their who have their funds frozen so
they can't access the money that they
have in PayPal so you know this often
happens to merchants actually who end up
accepting customers from different
countries or things like this they can
get flagged by PayPal's algorithms as
being potentially fraudulent and that
can put a hold on their funds in the
case of Chow me and E cash you'll notice
that we're not all running around using
digital tokens issued by banks chummy me
cash didn't really work out and that was
in part due to the fact that banks
weren't really interested in
implementing this technique so okay so
this is where we ended last class which
was we're in this situation where the
bank sort of has a lot of control over
payments and how payments happen and and
something I want to emphasize here as
well is you know this isn't it's not
just that we worry about this
because we want to do a legal activity
having an institution in the middle of
payments and sort of being able to
facilitate payments can can be a problem
in other ways as well because it can
just simply make things slower it can
make things it's harder to innovate it's
harder to introduce new features there's
a sign-up process so you know there are
reasons why we don't want to have an
institution in the middle even if we're
totally honest actors so the question so
where we ended up was how do we build a
decentralized digital token transfer so
we ended with tell me Andy cash and now
we're in this position where what we
want to do is we want to figure out how
to make payments without a bank in the
middle so there's a few problems that
we're gonna have to address in order to
make this happen okay
so first of all we really don't want it
to be possible for other users to
intercept a transfer of payment and
steal funds if our system can't support
this sort of very basic thing then no
one's gonna use it no one's gonna trust
it no one's going to rely on it so it's
very important that we have security
right another aspect of security is that
we don't want to allow people to spend
money without authorization there has to
be some mechanism by which we're really
sure it's Alice when Alice wants to make
a payment another thing another problem
that we want to avoid is a double spend
problem so what is the double spend
problem well oh and and equivocation
problem so what is the double spend
problem well when you have digital
tokens the problem with with digital
information is that it can really easily
be replicated right so you actually need
to think pretty carefully
it's the naive solution of just having a
unique string that you blast around at
your digital token doesn't really work
you have to do something extra to think
about how to ensure that these once a
token is spent it cannot be spent again
now what I mean by the equivocation
problem is you want to make sure that
once a spend happens it can
be taken back very easily right so if
I'm being paid by Alice I have some
confidence that once I actually receive
the money I've received the money Alice
can't renege on that promise okay so
these are some of the problems that we
want to solve with a with a
decentralized digital payment system and
here are some of the features that we
want to have which is kind of related to
some of the problems so first of all we
want to make sure that anyone can use it
that's what we mean by the word do you
centralized there's no single point of
control there's no one metering access
to this system if you want to make
payments if you want to join the system
you can join the system so anyone can
use it
we need a Thorat ativ transfer so that
we can be sure that when Alice produces
a transaction it's really her and we
believe that and we want to make it so
that you can't equivocate you can't undo
Spence so that translates into the
following sort of terminology that we
often use with these systems we want it
to be permissionless it doesn't require
permission to enter the system anyone
can join authoritative transfer no
double spends and can't undo we call
that being tamper proof so we don't want
it to be the case that someone could go
back and undo a spend another way to
think about that is we don't want people
tampering with history something that
would be really useful here and
something that the bank was kind of
keeping implicitly was a database of who
was transferring money to whom right
that was sort of the little the little
thing in the corner which said how much
was in Alice's account and how much was
in Bob's account um there are actually
techniques out there for maintaining a
decentralized database among a set of
participants this problem of needing to
agree on a value amongst many different
participants is a problem known as
distributed consensus so here's what
distributed consensus means and if
you've taken 8 to 4 then you've probably
seen this before but distributed
consensus is a problem of multiple
computers agreeing on a value
particularly in the presence of faults
so some of these computers might
or go away you can use this technique
distributed consensus to build a log of
operations with something called state
machine replication and essentially what
you have when you do this is a
distributed database which is what we're
trying to obtain here we need to keep
track of accounts and who's spending
what and what payments have happened in
the system and so distributed consensus
is a tool that we might be able to use
to do this so the reason that we might
be able to use distributed consensus to
do this is we could keep a log of all of
the transactions in the system so Alice
pays Bob David pace charlie and what
this log provides it provides ordering
so if Alice tries to pay Carol the same
thing that Alice pays Bob because we
have this primitive this log this
globally ordered log everyone can see
that this came after that one right
everyone can see that Alice was trying
to double spend Alice was trying to
spend the same coin twice so this
primitive is going to be really useful
this idea of this globally ordered log
of transactions it's kind of what
fundamentally underlines underlies all
of these things so you know we could we
could say if we were to see this log and
we were to see this transaction pop up
we can decide that this doesn't really
count that this is you know Alice
already spent her coin a property that
we want to maintain with these things is
that you can only spend a coin once so
therefore we're not really gonna allow
this to happen so as I said the the
problem of distributed consensus is that
when you have a whole bunch of people
working on this log you can tolerate
false so if some of the people go away
if it's only up to a certain number it's
okay you still have a consistent
globally order log so there's a lot of
existing systems that actually provide
this property some of them are Paxos
zookeeper and raft if you've ever heard
of them so the way that these protocols
work is that all of these participants
are executing the protocol to agree on
the log if if you fail the protocol can
so operate usually they can tolerate up
to
or a failing so these protocols the ones
that I just listed operating something
called the crash fault tolerance model
meaning they can handle computers going
away but not really much else and when
we're operating in decentralized digital
payment land we want to be able to
tolerate more than crashes we want to be
able to tolerate actively malicious
behavior because if you're gonna create
a digital payment system and it's money
then people are gonna try to steal that
money so like I said if people go away
if it's up to a minority you can still
have the log so there's stuff from the
literature that actually supports
something close to this there's
something called Byzantine fault
tolerance and Byzantine fault tolerance
tolerates more than crashes it actually
tolerates actively malicious
participants it can tolerate a smaller
number of actively participants up to a
third so here nodes might not just fail
they might actually try to subvert the
protocol to to keep from landing on a
single globally ordered log and like I
said we have protocols that can tolerate
this great however and these protocols
are very very old okay like visit the
Byzantine generals problem which was
sort of a basic formulation of what led
to Byzantine fault tolerance was
formulated in nineteen eighty-two Paxos
and view stamp replication also came
about in the eighties those are to
distribute consensus program protocols
practical Byzantine fault tolerance so
an actual like very practical protocol
that you can implement and that you can
use to create a globally ordered log
that was in the 90s and you know ever
since then we've had a lot of different
protocols so and then in 2009 Bitcoin so
this idea this idea of a globally
ordered log that can tolerate malicious
participants the thing I want to impress
upon you is that it's an old idea
decades old so what's new what happened
with Bitcoin well a downside the
all of these systems have is that you
need to know exactly who is
participating in the protocol so the way
that these systems work is as the
protocol works based on identity so you
have to know who is involved you need to
know everybody in the system you know
everybody in the system you can tell you
know as who's sending you messages and
who's not sending you messages and you
can make decisions about what everybody
else thinks the globally ordered log
looks like the thing that these
protocols did not tolerate was when you
don't know everybody in the system and
the problem when you don't know
everybody in the system
and you're not doing participation based
on identity is that an attacker could
create a whole bunch of identities
there's nothing preventing an attacker
from creating identities and remember we
want a permissionless decentralized
system we don't want to have some
gatekeeper saying who can enter into and
out of the system and given that we
don't want to have that gatekeeper we
can't just let people join willy-nilly
and manufacture their own identities
because if they do all of these
protocols all of a sudden no longer work
this is what's known as a Sybil attack
okay when an attacker can create
identities essentially for free and can
swarm the good guys and take over the
protocol so we're I'm gonna leave you is
with this problem which is we want to
figure out how to address the Sybil
attack problem when creating a globally
ordered log and and one way of doing
that is to think about making identities
costly so good guys can create new
identities and can join the system and
can execute the protocol bad guys could
potentially create identities and join
the system and execute the protocol but
because identities actually cost
something there's a limit there's an
inherent limit they don't come for free
the bad guys can only create so many and
that's where I want to end are there any
questions about that as we transfer over
to attach
yeah this percentage to deal with the
security consensus that's you have
synchronicity not necessarily so that
problem is unsolvable in the case where
there it a totally asynchronous system
but there's there's a lot of different
ways to create a model where for example
if you have random coins then it is
solvable in an asynchronous system so
this is something that you might have
heard of something called the cap
theorem this is sort of a predecessor to
that which indicates that in a totally
asynchronous system without random coins
consensus is actually impossible but
that's there's there's different ways to
sort of get around that and oftentimes
people assume that the system is semi
synchronous what oh sorry yeah
exactly and that's what Taj is going to
talk about yes okay everyone I'm gonna
talk about proof work which is in my Tim
in my estimation sort of the thing that
started all of this that you know
there's all sorts of cool cryptography
involved in Bitcoin and different
cryptocurrencies but it was the proven
where consensus that sort of kicked all
this off and it was the big difference
so we want to cost anyhow was mentioning
we want some kind of cost to create
identities or cost to participate in the
system how do we prevent civil attacks
and this is a very hard problem because
it tends to be an arms race in many in
many ways we're like you know Twitter or
Facebook or things like that have those
tons of bots because as soon as Twitter
makes a cool new algorithm to identify
what's a bot and kick them off the
system the various people who are trying
to make millions of Twitter BOTS start
to figure it out they're like hey they
banned all these BOTS well I'll switch
this around and you know make my BOTS
more human-like and better
I was actually kicked off of Twitter for
being a bot and I totally they say that
it exhibited automated activity so so
this is a hard problem and this is sort
of you know gets into like Turing test
CAPTCHA kind of thing as well but this
is Bitcoin is a fairly different
solution and as I said you don't want
really anyone in charge you don't want a
set identity list of people who can
participate so that rules out things
that that other systems use like let's
use Social Security numbers let's use
phone numbers let's use CAPTCHAs well
those don't really apply like what's a
social security number what if I mean
you know Germany and I want to use it
what if I'm in somewhere else you know
phone numbers as well phone numbers are
just administrated by a phone company
who would then become the de-facto
controller of the system and CAPTCHAs
are kind of an interesting idea and but
they you know the like identify the
signs in this picture or the cars in
this picture or whatever but it doesn't
really apply because it's not sort of
easy for people to verify and not easy
for computers to verify that like the
people were actually doing it so those
don't work so what does work is work so
I don't know if I think some people have
said they've they've some people said
like the first day oh I did problems
that one's like oh okay cool
some people have yet to start which is
fine as well but if you have started and
looked into problem set one great I will
talk about it a little bit in the next
few minutes the problem set needs many
attempts to forge a signature so if
you've done it you've I don't know what
the fastest probably someone got it to
work really fast when I completed it it
took I got it to run on a course of a
fairly fast machine and I got it to run
in like three minutes and it took me
something like two billion attempts
which it should write two billion is
around so this is because the hash
functions have random output right I'm
looking for a string where certain bits
are set and certain bits are free and
since the hash functions have random
output I have no shortcut this to be
like well I want an output where these
bits are ones and these bits are zeros
and the rest I don't care I can't really
specify that as the input to my hash
function so I just have to keep trying
different numbers right we know what we
want but the only way to get it is just
keep throwing in different numbers to
this hash function getting the output
and checking if it matches our criteria
so what do you want out of work in this
case you want it to be time consuming so
I'm kind of like the homework but the
example of the homework has some
problems because it's this weird trusted
set up right in fact it's so in the
homework case you're trying to forge a
signature where I have the private key
I've made four signatures and you want
to forge a fifth signature without my
private key the problem is it seems like
I would have an advantage in this work I
actually don't because you can verify
that I haven't revealed any new bits but
it but there's it's a weird setup right
where it's like okay well there's one
certain actor that like sets up this
whole work and like we shouldn't have
that kind
so you want it to be deterministic you
also want it to be scalable and you want
it to be memoryless where everyone sort
of gets a chance and you're not making
progress because if you are I'll get to
that later but if you're making progress
it tends to be that the fastest person
always wins
right it's if there's no randomness
involved like if it's you know let's
have a race between a bicycle and
someone running it's like well that's
not really a race ever the bicycle is
always gonna win whereas in this case if
it's memoryless every attempt is a new
shot at getting it and so someone who's
10% is fast will still win 10% of the
time okay so in the case of the homework
so here's an example where five bits of
eight are constrained so let's say these
first two you've got the preimages for
both the one you know this is the zero
row this is the one row and the the
signatures I've revealed okay you get
both bits here however here in this
place you only have the one bit being
the one preimage here you only have a
zero here you only have the one here
you've got both and then you're also
here one zero so the idea is these three
bits are like X like don't care either
either a 1 or a 0 will will work these 5
bits are constrained so it must match 1
0 1 and then 1 so you're gonna have to
keep trying messages and since 5 bits
are constrained you're gonna have to try
to the 5 messages which is about 64 yeah
which is totally doable right 64 tries
and you'll probably get it so for
example you try once and you say ok I
got 1 1 0 0 1 1 0 0 doesn't work these
are ok because they're ok no matter what
this one's wrong this one's ok this
one's okay this one's wrong let me try
again
but you okay I got it right these can be
anything
I got a 0 & 1 sure these all line up the
red ones all line up so I found a valid
solution and so that works as a
proof-of-work and in this case I found a
solution which was a tag forge
154 million two hundred sixty two
thousand one hundred seven and that's a
message that can be forged given those
four signatures in the problem set and
anyone can you know whatever homework
solution you have you can probably copy
and paste that string and check that you
know if you hash that you'll get a hash
that like matches up and can be signed
with those four signatures so the
question is did I do
one hundred and fifty-four million tries
to get that like did I start at zero
maybe I did more maybe it was random
maybe I got lucky and I started counting
at 150 million so it's not really a
proof is the thing like you're not
exactly sure how many attempts someone
did not quite approve right there's a
lot of chance however over many proofs
it's sort of averages out and you can be
pretty sure that someone's doing all the
work right so if you know if someone
gets lucky once fine like maybe they
they you know try it a couple times and
got a valid proof of work but eventually
if they keep doing proof of work and
they're you know
iteratively showing them then you can be
pretty sure that they're not they're not
gonna be lucky the whole time right and
so you have to kind of estimate the
collision difficulty the best way to
estimate the difficulty and the amount
of work that people have done isn't to
look at their proof isn't to look at
their nuts but to look at the
constraints of the system before they
start right so in the case of the
homework 31 bits are are specified right
so with four signatures you'd you'd
guess that about 32 bits would be and in
this case there's one bit difference so
in the case of the homework there's 31
bits that are specified so that means
you're gonna have to do about to be
billion hashes right two to thirty ones
like 2.1 billion or something and so
that's the best estimate of how long it
took regardless of what the nan says
regardless of what it looks like they
did you could say well it's gonna take
on average two to thirty one attempts
let's just and so if any valid solution
they give me I'm gonna sort of credit
that with two to thirty one work
so actually in the case of mine the one
is the thread number and there were
eight threads so this Taj Forge one 154
million so I had eight threads going in
parallel and that happened to be thread
one and so they all they all went about
the same speed so it's really like
hundred fifty four million times eight
which is about 1.2 billion and so that's
actually kind of lucky right like it
should it you would you would estimate
on average it would take two billion and
I got in like 1.2 billion so like pretty
good luck
but within you know within 2x of what
you'd expect and and since you can look
at like the probability distributions of
like that might be kind of interesting
with the homework like okay everyone's
attempt some people it takes to billions
some people get lucky and it takes 1
billion some people get unlucky and it
takes 5 billion and you're gonna have
this sort of curve to see it but this is
that's a kind of weird application of
this signature forging algorithm alright
it's it's sort of not what it's made for
it we can have a simpler proof of work
that has a specific target that's reused
forever and it's sort of more universal
and that it's not like oh here's this
private key you know here's this key
pair and here are these four signatures
where are these things coming from
that's weird we have to like match these
weird strings of bits and stuff that's
kind of annoying so it's better to do
something similar but much simpler we'll
just try to collide with a fixed string
so there's some defined string of ones
and zeroes and we just say okay well
let's try to have a collision with this
and the simplest is collide with zero or
you could also collide with like ffff
but in the case of Bitcoin in the case
of many of these systems we say well
let's just try to have a low number
so let's interpret the hash output as an
actual number in most cases do I have
any cashes out here no you know it's a
it's a 32 byte string and we think of it
as just like here's a blob of bytes but
you could cast that into like an integer
right you could say oh let's let's
interpret these 32 bytes as a you end
256 write a 256 bit unsigned integer
and let's look for really low once and
and you can do that I think with some
CPUs they'll actually like let you do
giant integers that way but even if not
you have like some kind of big int
library in your computer which just
interprets it that way and says okay
let's try to find collisions with zero
basically let's try to find low numbers
okay so this this idea there's a paper
before hashcash but I don't think cache
cache was the first software this idea
is actually really old in 1997
Adam back who still works on this kind
of stuff now with Bitcoin the idea was
to stop email spam which I don't know if
you know in the late 90s was actually a
huge problem they didn't have all the
cool like different machine learning
stuff and there's tons of spam and the
idea was okay put a nonce and a nun says
this we call this a nonce right the sort
of random number you're throwing in to
keep changing things put it nuns in your
email header and you try to get a low
hash output when you hash the whole
thing so you know within the UI for
email you don't necessarily have to see
okay what's this person's nuts
the computer just does it all
automatically for you but the idea is
you need a partial collision with zero
you need a low out hash output for your
email before your email the receiving
person will display the email and since
the header includes the like destination
address if you're a spammer and you want
to spam a million different people
you're gonna have to come up with a
million different proofs of work and
that could take quite a while like let's
say you know let's say an average CPU
can do it in two or three seconds that
means you're gonna have to be waiting
you know months to spam all these emails
however for a normal person if you're
just sending an email to your friend
takes a few seconds right takes two
seconds for your CPU time which is not a
huge deal um so this was a cool idea it
never really got off the ground just
because I don't know Gmail happened
hotmail happened a lot of webmail things
happen people don't really use yeah
yeah I mean spammers often have botnets
so yeah there's there's a lot of other
issues right like there's it didn't it
didn't take off for for various reasons
but yeah also spare some violence which
which also sort of hurts the whole idea
of proof-of-work in some cases which
we'll talk about in a second okay so the
simpler proving work so for example if
you go onto your computers and you say
echo
Tadgh four to three three nine six four
oh two four and pipe that to shock to
five six some you will get this output
and that's zeros in the front so that's
four bytes i did two to the thirty to
work and it you know that's me right and
so that proves that I'm a hard worker
and I'm gonna put this nonce on my
resume and everyone can see that like I
do work that you know it's kind of silly
but it's a really easy sort of universal
way to have a proof-of-work anyone can
put their name or any message and any
kind of months and we all just pipe it
into the sha-256 function and see how
low the output is in this case it's
actually two to the thirty three right
because the first digits of seven so
that's zero one one one but this is this
is what we use in Bitcoin it's what they
use in like a lot of these things I mean
it's really straightforward
okay so partial collision worth it it
has a lot of the properties what we're
looking for then when we want this
consensus system right it increases the
costs of equivocation and you know helps
with civil resistance in that if I want
to fool you I'm still gonna have to do a
lot of work and I need time to do that I
need electricity due to that I need a
bunch of computers to do that with also
scalable because a ton of work still
takes the same amount of time to verify
and space to verify as a little bit of
work right so I can do o of n work right
I can put as many zeros as I want and
the nonce doesn't really get any bigger
the nones never has to get bigger than
the hash output certainly and time to
verify is the same no matter what so
that's really cool
so why do we do work in the case of
Bitcoin
the idea is you used a chained proof of
work as a distributed time stamping
mechanism so it's to determine what
happened first so in the case of a
double spend where someone's saying oh
transaction a happened first and someone
else says well I think transaction B
happened first you can't just rely on
what other people are telling you
because who are these other people you
know there's no real identities here so
you look at what got into the chain of
hashes first and you say okay well that
one you know this one this data has a
hash of this data so it must have
happened after it right and the things
that happened before are pointed to by
the things that happened Africa because
the idea is I can't include the hash of
something that I haven't seen yet right
it should be impossible to do that so
the idea of the blockchain you've got
some message M some nuns let's call it R
and some target T and this actually
changes but we're not going to talk
about the changes yet so you tack the
hash of your message and the nonce like
I was doing with you note add in the
number and you say okay that's H and H
has to be less than some number T so in
the case where I just said you know my
notes I had to to the 33 work so you
know say say the same thing here in the
example I mean only require two bytes
for the target so that target needs to
be fairly large and then the message for
blah you know for block n includes some
data and also the hash of block n minus
1 so you refer to your previous block
hash in your current block data so for
example the message number 2 would be
data to concatenated with the hash of
data 1 + R there should be like R 1
there so I'll show you a little diagram
of this the idea of a block chain which
in this case we want low numbers as the
hash output you could do greater than
you could have I want something that
starts with a lot of F's it would
work the same there you know you could
yeah you want to constrain yeah so you
can you can do that with greater then
you can do that with a fixed sort of
yeah you know bits have to be well
there's something okay so less than and
greater than or actually nicer than just
fixed bit so you could say I want it to
start with the repeating pattern one
zero one zero one zero one zero that
would work too but then you're sort of
constrained in how fine-tuned you can
turn the knob and that you're gonna
either have to add another bit of
constraint or remove a bit of constraint
and so that you know you have to go in
to X jumps if what's nice with this is
you actually have very fine-grained
control over how or how much work you're
requiring because you don't so in this
example I've said hey I have you know
this many zero bits but I can also say
well I have I needed to have a number
less than seven F like less than seven F
0 0 0 0 here and this satisfies it
because hey that's 7e that's less than
7f right so I can I can actually have a
pretty like specific thing not just in
terms of number of bits specified so
like a greater than or less than it's
kind of nice in that sense because you
can have very small changes to the
target oh okay any questions about all
this crazy stuff
cool okay um yeah so you could you can
special in the in the case of the
homework it's just number of bits right
because they're all sort of scattered
throughout the field whereas in this one
you can say well it's the targets
greater than or less than in this case
less than so I have kind of find two
fine grained control which we're not
going to we will get into later but yeah
in in the actual case of Bitcoin the the
target can vary right so the you know
when Bitcoin started you needed four
bytes of zeros right you needed to do
two to the 32 work now you need to do
way way way more and there's an
algorithm in Bitcoin that sort of
adjusts what that target is and I'll
show at the end of this like a current
Bitcoin approved work
right right so time is sort of a tricky
semi ugly subject in Bitcoin it'd be
really cool to get rid of it but there
eight-time is used and only to vary that
target right so when you mine a block
you say I'm gonna put what time it is
and you look at the last two hunts when
every two weeks or so every 2016 blocks
you look at them and say okay what are
the what's the first time stamp of this
2016 period and the current time stamp
and if that took two weeks cool we don't
have to vary the target if it took less
than two weeks let's crank up the
difficulty or lower the target and it
and if it took too long let's make it
easier by raising the target and so
really you're only comparing the first
and last thing during the process when
everyone's downloading stuff if I think
the general rule is if you see something
that's off by more than two hours you
reject it but it's very lacks in terms
of synchronization right if someone's if
someone's 10 minutes off you're like
yeah sure I'll take it even if a block
even if like block 8 says it happened
before block 7 right refers to block 7
and yet has a time stamp that's before
it you're still like yeah ok fine
whatever
people's clocks are off so that the time
is fairly lacks you just the the person
who's doing the work time stamps it
you're fairly constrained right so like
it should be 2 weeks and you can say
well I bet if I am I'm off by 20 minutes
they'll everyone will be ok with it but
that's not a ton of control right if
you're if you're the last one of this
difficulty adjustment thing you could
say hey I'm gonna you know say it's I'm
gonna say what would you probably want
to do I'm gonna say it's 20 minutes in
the future because I want the difficulty
to not go up too much because I'm trying
to get more blocks so you could try to
push it to like 20 minutes in the future
from what it actually is and people all
the rest of the nodes in the network
will probably accept it but you get 20
you know 20 minutes
prints over a two-week period which is
like less way you know less than a
percent so yeah so so jet in the thing
is it's hard to like you don't really
necessarily know everyone's consensus
rules in these systems but I think the
default is two hours from your clock and
you like you know every client I've seen
will reject something that seems to be
more than two hours off but which is
really lacks right for most types of
distributed systems like two hours is
crazy like most of the time they're
gonna be within a few seconds so in AI
in general I don't think it ever is a
problem in terms of that so like yeah
but but people do okay so one of the
things they do which I can get to here
since there's a timestamp in the message
being hashed some chips that are
purpose-built for doing this work will
actually flip bits in the time stamp
flip the low-order bits because they're
like well no one cares what second it is
so I have a bit here that I can just
turn on and off and use as a nuns so
like the last the the lowest few bits
they just sort of randomize they're like
well if I'm off by five seconds no one
cares whether future fast so I'll just
use this as note space okay so but I'll
get into that a little more later so
anyway so so a block let's call this a
block has a bunch of data and then we
hash it right and in this case it's got
three things it's got a previous hash so
a pointer you know it specifies the
thing it's building off of it's got a
message so that you can add your message
that you're adding to the blockchain and
it's got a nuns so that you can prove
you're doing work and then these are the
things the actual data but then the
block itself has a hash right and this
hash is not included anywhere in the
block because it couldn't be right this
is the hash of this data and so we can
compute it but we can't we can't stick
this 0 0 DB thing here because that
would then change the data itself so the
idea is use these block hashes as
identifiers and in most of these systems
in general the hash of something is its
identifier is it sort of named the way
to point to it okay so the next block
includes a hash of the last block right
so here you saying okay the previous
block is zero zero dB you know you're
pointing to it and then you're adding
your own message oh hi
and you're adding your own nuts to make
you know and so you're when you these
two things you start out with you start
out with the pointer to the previous
block and then you say okay the message
I'm gonna try to add here is oh hi and
then you start grinding through these
right you start iterating or randomly
attempting different nonces until do you
found one where it's it's low right it's
got a bunch of zeros and you found and
so this is the nonce you need to specify
to get a lot of service and in this case
there's four characters of nonce and you
only need two characters of zero so like
it's way more non-space than you need
yes in this case there would be on
average 255 nan says that would work
right because I'm okay I haven't
actually specified these things but
assuming the target here is must be less
than oh oh ffs right so you need eight
zero bits in the front and all the rest
can be apps and you can have any notes
you want and this is an actual hash
function which is two bytes long that
means you've got two bytes here and only
one byte specified so you've got two to
the sixteen none space and your output
is constrained in two to the eighth so
you're gonna have two to the eight
different nonces that will work in the
case of Bitcoin
there's nowhere near enough nan says no
space right because your actual
constraint on your proof-of-work is a
lot of bits and you only have four bytes
or 32 bits of none space so what you
actually end up doing is using your
message as further none space right so
the thing is I could put oh hi - and now
I've changed my message which will
change my hash and so I if I if I go
through my entire nan space and don't
find a valid
of work I can edit my message and then
go through it again
so that it's a little ugly right it'd be
nicer if your non-space was big enough
that you've never had to do that in the
case of Bitcoin we don't know who
designed it and whoever designed it
didn't put enough in on space and so
it's kind of annoying but you can get
around it in theory you could just
eliminate the null space entirely and
say well just put it in the message
right but it's nice it's much easier to
think of when you're like here these
separate things like this is random and
has no real meaning this is the thing
that has meaning that we're going to use
see yeah the chain keeps building you
add work each time right bye okay
finding different notes is that that
match up with your message how are you
I'm good okay and the idea is if you
flip a bit in any block that's come out
so for example you change oh hi - oh hey
and try to leave everything the same
you're gonna change the hash so most
likely the proof-of-work will no longer
be valid right you know this starts with
a 9 now that's no one's gonna point use
it and and more importantly actually
these pointers stop working right
because I was this block was pointing
200 - see that's not this that's this
other one so basically you flip any bit
in the entire history of this chain and
it breaks right so you can't go back and
edit things you can't change messages
after the fact so it gives you the nice
property of immutability that once once
the message is included in the system so
in the case of money once a transaction
has moved funds from one place to
another you can't go back and change it
you can't undo something unless unless
you fork the chain so the idea is
everyone you know is running this system
sometimes inadvertently or sometimes on
purpose you can have two branches right
you can't have something point to two
different previous blocks right there's
one specified so in this case when I say
previous block it's a single specific
hash that I'm pointing to
and since we're pretty sure we can't
find collisions that means if I'm
pointing to zero zero dB it's only this
one which has the message hi I should
not be able to find two different blocks
which hash to zero zero DB because then
it's ambiguous and like wait which am i
pointing to so I shouldn't be able to do
that however it's easy to have two
blocks here that both point to the same
ancestor the post we call this a parent
well that's a child
plus a brand any so so this is easy to
do right - but different people can just
come up with their own messages and own
nonsense and point to the same ancestor
they could do this inadvertently because
they're not aware of each other's work
right where maybe these two things
happen at the same time and they're like
oh well we both found the answers at
about the same time or they could do it
maliciously where I saw that you made
this block and I saw that you made this
block and I'm gonna make these two
that's you know to try to confuse things
so this can happen in the rule in
Bitcoin and most all these systems is
okay well the highest walk chain wins
the most work wins so that's just our
metric for what we all determine is the
state of this system so everyone uses
the chain with the most work and that
can change right let's say we started
off with the eight zero zero eight a
being the chain tip that's what we call
the you know the current state of the
system and then someone came along and
said well I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid of
this thing
something happens in 94 that I want to
rewrite right I want to get rid of the
how are you message and I'm gonna
replace it with my own message and so
the way I do it is I branch off from o2c
make this one make this one and now drew
I've made another one so now this this
branch here has the most work and
everyone's gonna use it do and they sort
of forget about these two things like
yeah that was the tip you know that was
the most work state of the system but
now this is so now we have to go back we
have to erase these two messages and
these three messages and now everyone
agrees that that's the next state of the
system and this is called a reorg a
reorganization of the block this is sort
of bad but yeah they request it or
basically like someone says hey I have
these three and you're like really what
are those three and they give them to
you you're like okay
yep that works so the actual Network I
think in a few weeks we're going to the
actual like Network messages that are
used in Bitcoin but they're not they're
not like you actually if you wrote it
yourself you'd probably write something
more sensible and better it's a little
weird but basically you sort of knows
nodes in this network all are all
connected to each other and they report
on what they have and they say hey I
have oh oh six one and you're like
really I don't have a low six one and
you think maybe you owe six one builds
off here you request oh six one and
you're like oh it built off of here and
then they're like Oh ffff - I have a
three and so they build these you know
they request them all and build them and
then they actually keep these on in
memory for a little while and then event
but they don't think they save them on
disk so so you can have multiple like
different branches and concurrently in
your software and you just you know use
this and show this to DUI if one person
had a longer chain and
and everyone's out there getting it then
the network starts believing it great
yeah so so it's a gossip network so
basically there's no real identity for
all the different nodes of computers you
you also will report all the IE you
basically do it by IP address right so
when I connect to a node I don't think I
asked I think they just tell me like hey
here's a thousand IP addresses that I
know of that I've connected to that are
running this software and you're like
okay I'll add that into my list and then
you just sort of randomly connect to
people I think the default is randomly
connect to seven years and then when you
when anything comes in hey I got a new
message you know I got a new block
message you will tell all seven of your
peers hey I got a three and if they
request you know what what the data is
you'll give it to them so in in practice
things get propagated pretty well but
yeah partition attacks if you can
isolate so like if you can isolate this
off the network you may be able to
prevent this kind of thing from
happening so if you know someone built
these three blocks but isn't able to
broadcast it to the network then people
will still think that this is the most
the most work and build off of this so
yeah those are those are attacks that
can happen yeah
yeah um they stop being you know they
get undone so this is a very real risk
if you you know if you have a sort of
I'm you know alice is sending Bob five
bitcoins in this block and in this block
you have a conflicting transaction alice
is sending Carol five bitcoins you know
the same five bitcoins
Bob could think at this point hey I got
some money I have some money
oh shoot I don't have the money anymore
when this gets reorg doubt so that's
that is an attack right ends and you
have to be aware of that in using
Bitcoin or any of these kinds of systems
they're not you have consensus but I
think it's sort of like eventually
consent like so so generally the the
rule of thumb people use is like wait
six blocks I think that's in the
original Bitcoin white paper which is
fairly arbitrary like you know the
longer you wait the more certain it is
the more difficult it will be to perform
this kind of attack because you're gonna
have to do more work right and the idea
is everyone's building off of the one
that they think is the tip so everyone's
gonna you know you have to sort of get
pretty lucky or outrun everyone else to
perform this kind of attack so like in
aetherium and some other systems they
have uncles where you can point to
multiple ancestors which is weird
because your uncle's not really um the
so like that would that would let for
example that would let of' to point to
both oh six one and oh nine four
the answer is no these are not uncles
yeah there's a separate thing this is
not uncle's but related right you could
draw like you could draw an arrow there
okay so I'll talk about sort of pros and
cons and some of this gets into not as
objective and somewhat subjective ideas
but it's an interesting thing to talk
about especially in contests of money
okay so pros anonymous memoryless
scalable non interactive I'll go through
all these kind of the real world
Conn's pretty much all Monza's fail it
uses watts uses chips
there's 51% attacks and people hate it
so the pros there's they're quite good
it is anonymous right you can mine
without any kind of identity even after
you've mined you don't really have to
say who you are
there's no pre known keys there's
there's actually no signatures involved
right there's no public key system at
all you're just you know trying
different notices anyone can go for it
every attempt is equally likely to
succeed since it's random and it's not
limited to humans so you could have you
know you don't need a social security
number bots are welcome any anything can
mine and everyone you know doesn't
really care who mined it it's not about
who it's just oh there's a none stairs
work okay this is valid so that's really
cool it's memoryless this is important
and a little counterintuitive in some
ways there's no progress so if you have
10 trillion failed nonces your next
month's is just as likely to fail which
is extremely likely so that makes it a
possible process right which is you know
it's a certain probability distribution
kind of thing you will always expect the
next block in ten minutes from now so
hey it's been 20 minutes since the last
block came out when's the next one
coming out probably 10 minutes there you
know and there's no it's sort of like
you know there's no progress being made
you you always you have no memory of
what the last few minutes have had so
the fact that it's been 10 minutes the
fact that I miss or it's been 2 seconds
you still think it's gonna take about 10
minutes which is nice because it means
like there's a linear trade-off between
how many attempts you're making and what
your chances of finding in the next
block are so if you attempt twice as
many you have twice as good a chance of
finding the next block which is good
because if there is progress right if
you had some kind of function where the
probability was non not just linear a
number of chances but if it was like
super linear exponential
or something like that you the fastest
person would always win right so if it's
like okay I need to compute this thing
and it takes a couple trillion
computations and so for some computers
it takes five minutes for some computers
it only takes two minutes the computers
that can do it in two minutes
are just always going to win because the
people who take five minutes to finish
it well they just did it in two minutes
and like I can't keep up with them so
this is really nice and it makes it
competitive otherwise it would end up
being like whoever's fastest just
consistently can perform the work any
questions about memory lists it's kind
of this is this I mean you guys actually
know computers and stuff and math you
know MIT but this is like a fairly
common misconception in Bitcoin and
other systems like this where people get
mad like it's been an hour and no blocks
come out it's like well yeah you know
awesome process on average every day and
a half there will be a one-hour gap and
then people have been like well the last
three blocks came out and like you know
two minutes so there's gonna be awhile
before the next block it's like no no
there's there's no memory so so there's
a lot of you know it's misconceptions
when it's a purely random system that
people are not used to this kind of
thing so but it but it's kind of
intuitive right like even I sort of
think like oh you know and like no no
memoryless got to remember that got to
remember in this memory loss
okay so scalability is actually kind of
amazing so this is a block hash from
this morning or late last night that
actually happened in Bitcoin and there's
a lot of zeroes there's 18 of them and 9
bytes and actually more because it
starts with a 3 instead of a math for
something so what's really cool about
this is it takes just as long to verify
this work as it did with the one with my
name right which only had 4 bytes of
work you know and the one with my name
it took my computer I don't know 20
minutes or whatever to do this took
computer you know this one took
ten minutes right but it took the
network ten minutes because everyone's
participating at the same time so yeah
it's and it's a trillion times we're
working takes no more time to verify
that's really cool and it is kind of
like amazing because this is almost a
mole of attempts like Avogadro's number
so you're getting into numbers that like
you never deal with these scales of
numbers in I mean you do it in my
chemistry but so so that's that's a nice
property also it's not interactive in
that that helps as well so you never
have to report your failed attempts
right so you can have a thousand
different computers all trying one nones
with you know different messages or one
chip trying a thousand times and you
don't need any communication between
them so the only communication between
the network is when a block has actually
found so there's no real setup
needed so it's a very simple message
protocol where you just say hey here's a
block everyone just sort of broadcasts
so that's really cool too
so these are all really useful
properties for our network in our
consensus system also it uses real world
resources so when you want to go back
and rewrite history even if a majority
of participants want to do that they're
still going to be a cost so that's
that's pretty unique compared to many
different sets consensus systems in many
systems say okay well we have unanimous
agreement all participants in the system
are going to rewrite history we're gonna
go back for 10 that never happened and
you know branch off and create a new
history even if everyone in Bitcoin
every participant tries to do that
they're still gonna have to spend that
that energy and that work and so that
really discourages reorganize history
even when everyone wants to so that's
kind of cool and that like you're you're
tied down not just by the other
participants in the system but by sort
of physics itself and like the way the
world works like we are gonna have to do
work to rewrite this so that's and and
also it shows that people are sort of
invested and they've done work so that's
kind of cool - okay so any any
about all these pros or if you want to
say some of these pros are actually cons
before I get to the cons okay go to cons
and this is all oh it's always more fun
to complain about stuff so we can go
into cons and and I'm sure people can
jump in with other things like yeah this
is bad so one problem is that it's
inefficient almost every attempt fails
so that's no fun right so the proof of
work from a few hours ago
this is ten to the twenty two attempts
and all - you know there's ten to twenty
two failed attempts that were required
you know that will happened in order to
get that one so that's like extremely
inefficient you know your I don't know
how to express that as a percentage but
the actual like things moving the system
are some incredibly small percentage of
the actual things happening it's also
problem because you're not gonna be able
to get a valid block right if you have
to do two to the 72 attempts like you're
just not gonna do it like ever you can
run your laptop for your entire life and
you will not be able to do two of the 72
work which is kind of depressing even if
you buy specialized hardware yeah you're
not gonna you're not gonna find a block
it sort of consolidates until you need a
you need a factory you need a warehouse
full of equipment basically in order to
do this now so that's kind of annoying
right it's not as fun like the small
players have been pushed out of the game
because you need to do so much work in
order to have you know you can't get
sort of hey I came close can I get like
partial credit can I you know I did I
did to to the fifty work and I get
anything for that the system doesn't
recognize partial work okay
other cons it uses wats and chips uses
lots of electricity you could use that
electricity to charge your car or do
something cool it uses fabs to make
microchips which could make more CPUs or
make cool phones or something
once it gets big enough it actually
starts affecting markets so I don't know
if I just know in micro Center
they're like many times that because I
live near there and like you go around
and like there's the GPU section and
like everyone complains about Bitcoin in
micro Center near the GPUs it's not
Bitcoin aside it's usually like
aetherium another other coins that that
use GPUs for mining what that has had a
really big effect on the market for GPUs
a lot of people because you can make
money with them so people are like yeah
buy one of these things for 500 bucks
because I'll make back my 500 bucks in a
year and then I'll you know still have
the chitin still have the GPU that maybe
I can sell it used and get a couple
hundred bucks back and then I profited
so so these things affect you know it's
big enough that it affects markets
initially it didn't because it was just
a couple nerds running Bitcoin and so
like who cares you know a couple people
buying GPUs but now it's big enough you
know these are like billion-dollar
markets and it's getting to be the same
sort of scale as the you know gamer
market your gamer or like whatever CUDA
or whatever people use GPUs for but it
you know mining is significant and so it
affects the market who knows someday you
could start to affect electricity prices
if you get big enough where a
significant portion of all the
electrical usage in the world or the
country is going into doing this sha-256
and so that makes electricity prices go
up and then everyone starts complaining
like me and electricity is twice as much
as it used to be because all these
people mining bitcoins and it's possible
if it gets big enough instead of just
people complaining about GPS so that's
sort of a con right that's it starts
affecting the real world in big ways the
corollary of that being a memoryless
process is that it's irregular
it's a Poisson process which means
sometimes you get in a few seconds and
sometimes it takes an hour and people
don't like that right you you I can see
how you'd rather have something come out
regularly a lot of people think yeah
blocks come out every 10 minutes well on
average every 10 minutes but it can be
hours it can be seconds and so that
that's hard in some cases you can't
really use it like hey I want a you know
regular clock or I want message
that come out in some kind of I want
some assurance right if I make a mess
you know I make a transaction I want it
to be included in this system I want
some assurance it will be included in
the next 20 minutes you don't get that
assurance right it can be 30 minutes
before anything gets included and in
fact we'll get into later but there's
even worse assurance properties in that
like just because five blocks came out
doesn't mean your transaction got into
any of them they might have been ignored
it might you know there's all sorts of
reasons so you can deal with this but it
is kind of annoying and it precludes
some use cases and other consensus
systems do not have this problem other
consensus systems can have much more
regular clocks so this is kind of
annoying as well any questions about the
irregularity aspects okay big con 51%
attacks okay part of the problem with
anonymity is you have no idea who's
doing this stuff right even if they say
who you know even if they claim so the
one interesting part of anonymity
despite this being designed as a really
cool hackery cyberpunk anonymous system
one of the first things people did was
put their name in it right so if you
mind a block you've got space where you
you know you can put 32 bytes or so that
are undefined and people would just
start putting the names of their mining
pools or their names of their cat or
whatever they just put their names in it
so it's kind of like they're showing who
they are and you can look at like
distribution of like who are the
different miners and stuff like that's
like even though it's supposed to be
anonymous so they claim but they can
claim a name and they can claim this
block was mined by f2 pool or this MOC
was mined by BTC com but you're not a
hundred percent sure right it's all I
could also mine a block and claim that
it's from f2 pool and it's hard to
disprove so you don't really know who's
mining and an attacker with 51% of the
total network power can write a chain
faster than everyone else combined so
that means they can rewrite history
right so like in the example before
where hey
made this three blocks longer than these
two blocks
I had to either get lucky or you know
everyone else stopped mining for a
second
but that's not really possible long term
if I have a minority of the hash power
right because everyone's just gonna
start you know if the money if the
majority is sort of honest and playing
by the right rules they're just gonna
see what the most you know the longest
work the most work the longest chain is
and start throwing blocks on top of that
and if I go back and try to make a
branch the main branch will grow faster
than my sub branch and so I'll never
overtake the main branch and so I'll
never be able to reorg
however if I am faster than everyone
else put together its assured that I
will eventually you know catch up and
overtake the rest of the network and
then everyone will have to reorder on to
mine so you know here's the main chain
and then I branch off here and I'm
faster so I you know overtake them and
then that's sort of everyone's stuck
right even if they want to keep mining I
can just reorder them out every time
because I'm bigger this is a this is
called a 51% attack it's pretty bad an
attacker can rewrite history can undo
transactions they can't Forge
transactions right so they can't
necessarily reorg out a message and
replace it with a message of their
choosing all they can do is you know if
they can but they can do that with their
own messages so you sort of need to to
have this as part of an attack where
they reorg their own messages out by
default when a reorg occurs so like I
can go here so by default when a reorg
occurs and like say these two blocks of
messages have been invalidated software
will attempt to include all the
transactions in these blocks into the
next blocks right it's not just because
this got reordered out doesn't mean it
was invalid it just means it didn't you
know it didn't get into a block and so
we can try to include the
message later as long as nothing in here
conflicts with it so just doing a 51%
attack to reorg doesn't on its own
doesn't actually do very much damage
however you it's not too hard to cook to
sort of combine that with other attacks
where you know whoever's doing this
mining says oh I'll pay someone here and
then pay myself here and then you know
undo the payment that they made to solve
so that's a big big con 51 percent of
tax not only is it like very disruptive
to the system you it's very hard to
predict when it'll happen since it's
anonymous you know it could be the case
that all the people mining Bitcoin now
are friends and they're you know a 51%
group and they could just you know get
together and say hey let's read about
these things that said there's there's a
cost to do so so if you have you can see
it must be much much easier there's very
little work being done in the system
it's probably pretty cheap to get a
bunch of hardware and be 51% of that
system true so like and in the case of
Bitcoin if you have to do two to the 72
work well in every ten minutes that
means if I want to be 51% I have to do
two to the 71 work every 10 minutes
which that's a lot of work and so you
know you're gonna need enormous amounts
of resources to become a 51% attacker
there's sort of two ways this this
attack can happen either some attacker
comes out of nowhere and says okay I'm
just gonna build up an enormous amount
of attack power or the existing actors
in the system sort of go bad which seems
more likely where they're like okay
we're we already you know I'm five
percent he's ten percent and she is 20
percent and they all sort of get
together and try to do an attack so both
of those different ways are possible
joining from my pool we said who does
like small players yes like and fishes
yes pools we didn't haven't mentioned
pools but the idea part of the the con
of you're never going to find a valid
proof of work is the way they mitigate
that is then people sort of get together
in pools and they will prove partial
work to each other and sort of there's
one entity that's then sort of controls
a lot of different minors and gives out
the room give us out partial rewards so
ok there's a thousand different people
mining and one of them found the block
but I'll I'll distribute that reward to
all the thousand people for all the work
they've done and so that that does
concentrate power in that you know sort
of mining pool whoever's running it so
that's all that can also be a big
problem yeah and and because if you're
doing it solo now he's so sort of solo
mining is saying I'm just mining on my
own I'm gonna try to find a valid proof
of work that's very difficult because of
the amount of work needed so many people
pool together so yeah that's another
issue
yeah there's also protocols one called
p2 pool where you can sort of have
another layer of blockchain II kind of
messages which allows you to pool
together resources without having a
single entity responsible for like
getting the rewards and distributing
them back out I mean I've really talked
about the like rewards and like the
Bitcoin specific stuff will be in next
week probably but but yeah there's all
sorts of this gets really complicated
and crazy in like pools there's so many
attacks on pools and it's it's a mess
okay
last con people hate it and this is not
a quantitative objective reason but it
is a problem and people don't like
proof-of-work
some people are fine with it but a lot
of like especially in academia that I've
talked a lot of people they're just like
ah this is horrible you know the whole
point of shot to v6 is you can't find
collisions and you design an entire
system we're all we're doing is trying
to find collisions in this non
collidable system and you've got you
know giant warehouses full you know uses
so much electricity and you've got giant
warehouses full of chips that are just
doing this pointless thing but it's you
know it offends the sensibilities of
many people and it and it probably is
getting worse because it keeps getting
bigger and so a lot of people don't like
it and I I can understand that like when
I first read about this stuff I was like
that's kind of cool that's kind of
stupid and then I was like oh man what
if this gets really takes off there's
just gonna be so much power usage and so
many chips dedicated to like kind of a
pointless thing I I would say that like
I acknowledge this is a big problem and
I think the best analogy is something
like gold or silver they know precious
metal mining where you could make very
similar arguments that you know like all
these you know Spanish or Portuguese
people sailed over to South America five
hundred years ago and it was sort of it
was you know horrible and all these
people are like working in these mines
and it's like a mess just to get silver
or gold or whatever it's like why
why are you doing this right just to get
some gold so similarly the the Bitcoin
and the proof of work in general has a
lot of people who don't like it and so
that's why there's a lot of research in
okay can we have the same kind of system
but without the work or alternatively
can we have some kind of proof of work
that's also useful for other things so
can we have some kind of proof of work
that like cures cancer it's like wow I
mean there's there's actually write
papers about like protein folding proof
of work and I don't I don't I haven't
seen a ton there's one where you like
find sequences of prime numbers and it's
sort of work it sort of has most of the
properties you want and it's like okay
but it's like well you found five prime
numbers in a row like yeah so that's
another yeah people want useful proof
work a lot of times with useful proof of
work it's hard to tell that it's a valid
proof or you know there's not as much of
a gap like the gap in in Bitcoin is
enormous right
Oh of n takes o of one to verify which
is like perfect
yeah you can't get better than that
so so yeah it's hard to verify there's
also that also applies to many different
proofs of work so so one of the things
with 51 percent of tax is if like you're
saying if you want to build your own
coin if you use the same proof of work
algorithm as Bitcoin you are in a very
risky situation because you've started
your own new coin that like you know
your own new message network that very
few people are using and there's very
little work being done in this network
and then there's this huge Bitcoin
network and as soon as they see your
network they could easily overpower it
right one one actor one person who's
mining could become more than 51 percent
of your network just with a flip of us
you know pressing a button and so it's
very dangerous to be running a very
small network that shares a
proof-of-work with the larger network
and so most of the different coins when
people say hey I'm gonna make my own you
know derivative of Bitcoin or my own new
coin I'm gonna have a different proof of
work and so there's all sorts of
different hash you know maybe I'll use
shot three instead of shot 256 okay or
I'll use some other hash function or
some other like usually iterative hash
function like for password hashing are
you actually in a passion several
million times and the disadvantage there
as well as it can take quite a while to
verify the the work not too much but
noticeable where if you're running
different clients like litecoin for
example it uses a proof-of-work which
takes thousands of times longer to
verify still fast enough but some of
them are pretty heavy so so those are
all the different you know it gets
pretty messy and I'm you know if you ask
probably James and some other people are
much more familiar with all the like
horrible intricacies of proof of work
yeah yeah so there's one wait
so I said the longest so if you say the
longest chain is the valid one I think I
mostly said most work right they're not
necessarily the same right in this case
where we have a fixed target you know
fix the amount of work per block they
are the same but in the case of Bitcoin
and most of these networks the the
target and the amount of work required
for a block can change right with that
2016 period and so there are attacks
where you can say well I'm gonna make
something that's longer but actually has
less work because I've forged all these
times that you know I go back in time I
pretend it took me a long time and I
change the time stamps so that it looks
like it took a long time and the
difficulty decreased and then but I
actually have more blocks but less total
work and then I can have some weird
attacks where I like reorg out things so
in the case of Bitcoin I think yeah
pretty early version 1.0 version 0.1 it
actually just looked at
of blocks because it's so much easier in
the code to just do number of blocks you
know otherwise you have to like treat
all the hashes as bigots and like figure
out how much work was done on each one
and this annoying stuff but that attack
was sort of thought of it I don't think
the attack ever happened but the whoever
designed it was like oh wait yeah
longest is not quite right it has to be
most work and so they changed the code
okay so proof worked we played it yeah
but the thing is it does work it's been
working for nine years the blocks keep
on coming not regularly but you know
over the course of a day about a hundred
and forty four will come out in practice
it's infeasible to write old messages
right you you there are all these known
attacks but they're very costly and and
either you have to do an enormous amount
of work and get all these resources or
you have to sort of have a lot of
collusion between the different actors
one nice part is that in these systems
people are very adversarial and so they
don't want to collude they always are
attacking each other and hate each other
so it's so that sort of keeps the system
working in practice with Bitcoin there
are very few blocker York's this happens
I don't know when's the last time actual
reorg happened instead of just two like
years it just never happens most one or
two blocks so you can have a one block
where two blocks
come out at the same time and point to
the same parent but that's not a reorg
right because then your software sees it
it's like well which is gonna be right
and then one of them pulls ahead so that
happens every couple days it used to be
more frequently but now it's fairly
infrequent and like two blocks reorg it
has happened but it's it's very rare now
so you can build on these things
okay I'm almost done new one last fun
facts and then questions ok so fun facts
how to estimate the total work done
throughout history of the network well
you just look at the lowest - this is a
kind of like counterintuitive like whoa
kind of thing you can prove all the work
ever done in the history of the system
with just one
the lowest because probabilistically
like well I've been doing work the whole
time probabilistically I guess the the
way this works is that whether we were
all trying for the same block or whether
we are trying for all these different
blocks it doesn't matter right we're
still doing attempts and the best
attempt will have the most zeroes in
front of it and that holds true for
whatever kind of configuration graph
configuration whether there's Forks
whether this a single chain whether we
all just work on the same thing and you
know never make any progress and just
submit the best hash so that's kind of
cool you can just look at a single hash
and see all the work that's ever been
done in the system kind of cool with
with pretty crummy accuracy of course
but but actually not too bad and so
there's a paper that's pretty
interesting if you're interested in like
this and want to look into the math
there's a paper called hyper log log
that uses this fact for something
completely different to like count set
cardinalities and stuff and it's kind of
a cool math paper but but I think the
Bitcoin software does do that and it'll
say like best hash and it's in there you
can say like well this is how much work
we've all done there's also some papers
in Bitcoin where you can try to use
these facts like the lucky blocks that
happen to have much more work than they
needed and you can look back through
history and sort of given a bridged
version of history that still took as
much that would still take about as much
work to rewrite without providing all of
the different headers the different
blocks and stuff you can also prove
close calls so like with pools and
mining one way you can do it is you can
prove that you are trying but didn't
quite make it so if the if the
requirement is you need two to the forty
leading zeros and you get two to the
thirty-nine you can show like hey I got
two to the thirty-nine and I didn't
quite make it but you know I tried and
then people can verify that work as well
and like credit you for that so the way
a mining pool works will be you give
what's called shares which is like you
know close calls that it were were not
sufficient to meet the proof of work but
you keep you keep giving them every few
seconds or every few minutes and then
the central pool operator says okay well
this person did this many shares this
person did this many shares I have you
know the central operator has a very
good estimation of how much work
different people are doing and so
credits them and said okay well he's
doing this much work he's doing this
work and then when someone actually
finds the block distributes the rewards
from the block proportionally to how
much work everyone's been doing
so that's trusted and not great and
there's also a bunch of attacks the sort
of sneakiest of which is keep submitting
shares submitting close calls but when
you actually do find a valid proof of
work immediately forget about it drop it
and never tell anyone the reason that's
a good attack is fairly counterintuitive
but it's a good attack even though it
seems like well you just found the block
you know tell everyone you get this you
know reward you get it's like nope no I
found a block throw it away but oh I got
a close call okay keep telling the
central operator what that does is that
really screws over the central operator
who now thinks you're doing a lot of
work but you never find an actual block
and eventually the central operator like
this person's really unlucky huh he's
found so many close calls but never
seems to actually get over the line and
find a valid proof of work
and so maybe they can kick you off
eventually but it's it's not something
you can prove you're like well I got
unlucky so there's all sorts of things
there's all sorts of fun things you can
do with the proof of work and this you
know just these hash functions
you